across much of southern Britain it's
been snowing all night and plenty have
already been caught up efforts to clear
the chaos on the a13 air temple in
Cornwall haven't stopped motorists who
defied the weather warnings were caught
out in a blizzard more than a hundred
cars were left as some abandoned their
vehicles and braved the journey home on
foot Cornwall bore the brunt of the
first wave there were also treacherous
conditions just outside exeter with a
trail of traffic there too it seems
although fed up commuters weren't
surprised the rest of the world survives
for those storms but Devon County
Council survived three centimetres
really bad you couldn't see two or three
cars in front of you and quite heavy
snow at a time it's died off now a
little bit and yeah just cold and feel
sorry for people with children and the
elderly and stuff you know it was cool
here both seven year ago it's not the
same as five hours so we're not five
hours tonight the Met Office say more
than 12 centimetres of snow was recorded
in Bodmin and more than a hundred
schools will be closed in Cornwall and
Devon this morning officials have warned
motorists to be fully prepared if they
need to venture out onto the roads make
sure you've got full visibility all
around your vehicle that your vehicle is
ready for the road you've got plenty of
fuel you've got your washer bottle
topped up a little bit of food a little
bit of drink if you need medication and
we would say always say within the next
24 hours then take some of that
medication with you and then it's lots
and lots of warm clothing
councils across the UK had tried to
prepare for this
they had one point four million tons of
salt stockpiles and greeters had been
working through the night to clear the
roads it was all hands on deck
volunteers with tow trucks have been
helping to pull cars free from the snow
we've told probably collectively about
20 or 30 cars up on Holden Hill the
worst sort of area in the forest people
start using the four drives Land Rovers
violence's to pull them out letting them
deflate their tires to get more great
the snow moved eastwards and into London
overnight as the country awakes to a
blanket of snow commuters are warned
that this icy grip won't loosen anytime
soon alie thought askew Sky News
[Applause]